hey this is just a quick funny thing I
want to call to your attention I got an
email yesterday from Kaelyn who watches
the show and also watches the great
Anthony Fantana
you might remember Anthony Fantana
because he's been on the show before
years ago he did a special with former
producer Louis where they reviewed heavy
metal albums and he has two really big
youtube channels one called the needle
drop where he does exclusively movie
reviews and movie relay usek reviews and
music related content more than a
million subscribers hugely successful
channel then he has another channel
called Fantana which is much smaller
than the needle drop but still has more
subscribers than we do and he talks
about more things outside of music
including a video about how to be
articulate and halfway through the video
he gives the David Pakman show
a shout-out and a bunch of people
emailed me and said hey Anthony Fantana
sent me he talked about you check out
the very nice part of the clip from
Anthony's channel be present while
you're talking think about all the
things that you're saying and what they
are going to communicate who you are
saying them to so I would highly
recommend James Randi I would highly
recommend David Pakman over on the david
pakman youtube channel he has a great
political youtube channel that in my
opinion is very fair very balanced and
while I do watch a lot of different
political YouTube channels David Pakman
in my opinion is one of the best in
terms of just having very clean very
even speech and tone and delivery it's
very calming it's very easy to digest
it's not very heated or aggressive or
sort of out of pocket or anything like
that and look there are some political
youtubers who I like who you know do get
heated in their delivery I do like to
see maybe some Young Turks every once in
a while I do like to watch Kyle over a
secular talk and this is not a you know
a diss to them but I don't necessarily
watch those channels because I think the
delivery is super articulate or anything
like that I would say it's it's more
passionate than it is articulate but if
you're going to take the time to listen
to other people speak just make sure
they're individuals who you think are
speaking well actually speaking well
good advice
great segment check out the Anthony
Fantana channel check out also the
needle drop it's all great stuff and
really appreciate that he mentioned me
and he every once in a while shows up in
the super chats on the our occasional
YouTube live streams and really
appreciated and go check out his work
because it's really really good